[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'appelle david coa depuis je
suis le président et fondateur de la
société ivalua donc il va lui avec une
solution en mode saas
solutions logicielles pour gérer les
achats pour les grandes entreprises
notre but principal c'est d'aider ces
grandes entreprises à gérer l'ensemble
de tous leurs types d'achats et de
pouvoir collaborer avec l'ensemble de
tous leurs fournisseurs en temps réel et
de façon optimisée
on est localisée sur plus de 17 bureaux
au travers du monde notre siège social
se trouve à massy dans la zone paris
saclay nous sommes dans une forte
croissance depuis pas mal d'années plus
de 30 % de croissance sur ces dernières
années notre ambition c'est d'être
l'acteur majeur sur ce marché qui est un
très grand marché le marché des gestions
de la gestion des achats pour les
entreprises c'est un grand marché de
plus de 50 milliards de 2 en termes de
taille de marché
je suis ravi d'avoir été invité à être
le parrain de la nouvelle édition
de spring paris saclay pour moi c'est un
un vrai honneur de pouvoir être ses
parrains pour pouvoir apporter
l'expérience que j'ai d'avoir créé la
société il ya maintenant plus de 20 ans
en démarrant de chez moi à
gif-sur-yvette ensuite on s'est installé
dans la pépinière d'entreprises de
courcelles sur yvette qui est aussi dans
la zone et puis ensuite nous avons
déménagé à orsay et là a tout récemment
nous venons d'implanter notre siège
mondial à massy dans la zone atlantis
donc vraiment j'ai baigné dans cette
dans cette région je dirais même que
personnellement j'ai aussi un
attachement fort ce que j'ai fait
l'école polytechnique et ensuite j'ai
poursuivi en faisant une thèse de
mathématiques et notamment en
travaillant à l'université paris-sud
orsay et puis aussi à l'institut de
physique nucléaire je suis du coup ravi
de parrainer cette nouvelle édition de
voir éclore toutes ces start-up de
pouvoir les aider du mieux que je peux
en apportant l'expérience que j'ai sur
ben plus dans le domaine de l'édition de
logiciels saas mais aussi la croissance
d'entreprises de la levée de fonds de
pouvoir grandir à l'international et je
serais ravi d'apporter cette expérience
à toutes les start up qui vont se
présenter dans cette nouvelle édition
[Musique]